yeah welcome to this video playing a
five-minute game against the very high
rates of player here from Israel true
move I don't think I played him before
okay I went for my tried and trusted 1e5
a fourth bedroom we should be forced to
move to to go but I really forgot the
details
yeah I think you take it and then go
with before but this is really a long
time so that I that I check this line if
you take that play knight c6 out I'm on
d 4 + B form of course it doesn't take
it so clear now I think c5 but
complicated yeah must be a bit cautious
he's got the two bishops of course this
is always something to consider and this
night only five ism um yeah let's say
control controversial piece it can be
very a good but can also be a bit of a
problem very good means that i can go to
sephora initiate play on the queenside
but can always be a real pest this piece
i don't really get Bishop g5 I want to
exchange I don't mind that at all and
transferring this piece to be six for
example is also often a good idea night
before you go all the way back yeah
mmm yeah
yeah but it doesn't really lead to much
i could play b 3 C 4 and Bishop c5 I'm
not sure about this
okay this should be okay in any case so
c4 maybe c4m contending Bishop c5 at
some stage also rupee aid as a
possibility I don't have I'd I like my
chances on the queenside but it's of
course not clear-cut bishop age 6 okay
let's let's prepare Bishop f8 if he goes
bishop age 6 they might be able to take
and play rugby tube Wow where's he going
maybe not deform not deform okay I need
to I need counter play rugby too
I want night be three he that needs to
take him
yeah this cannot be bad for black away
so maybe this one so that I immediately
attacks III yes but term is it doing so
much I take on see 39 f 52 sugar 6 not
sure
I don't see at the moment what it is
doing
please look see one or something I play
Roxy to em now you can play this and
night h6 yeah this is this is right
okay the still um should be a perpetual
only I'm download time so I don't mind
if he makes the draw now he maybe has
anything back maybe had something better
of course check but I don't see at the
moment okay place a place on not sure
yeah I got the beep on I can young like
you can take and Bishop age six or
something
King King King here Bishop age six not
sure I've always 96 to interpose a
bishop age six now translators now and
take down of course yeah well I simply
spoiled a winning position here he had
nothing on the Kings side absolutely but
I allowed allow I simply allowed too
much I was simply winning with the extra
pot on the queenside yeah but it's it's
always easy afterwards if you look at
this the computer just shows plus
something and you still need to find it
in the game which i didn't manage
I can just take okay have success over
the Linton's yeah now let's check how I
could have one I mean I would be really
surprised it wasn't at least a very
distinct advantage so how much do we
have here minus one point something for
black yeah that's better for white then
I thought okay I took yeah right here is
0 0 0 okay check ok usually the computer
1 says you must make a draw yeah I
suspected this this is probably nonsense
but you need to instill refute it
Brooksie 2 and this is still around
equal yeah and yet it's tricky already
it's tricky probably that I didn't need
to allow this night age 6 f 7 but it was
difficult yeah look see to Roxy to UM oh
look a tune I play tonight f8 yeah I
wasn't sure at this happiness singing of
course but I have this counter play with
Roxy to look at you
check check check now here this weekend
of course I just overlooked her gently
babe bishop age six yeah yeah otherwise
this was quite quite decently played I
think here the computer wants to donate
c5 yeah it's looking okay but i don't i
can add it also it takes before of
course i didn't pay any attention to
that yeah 95's is strong with him
no it detects avoid protects f7 so after
night f5 I can just just drop back to
have eight I want and it's better on f8
to defend and the on the queenside I'm
clearly better anyway already so I just
need to make sure they're not i'm not
getting mated or something okay thanks
for watching